now we've seen no shortage of policies
announced by the political parties in
the recent days and weeks but how much
can we trust what is being said to us
let's talk to our economics editor Eddie
Conway who's been looking into the
detail behind the promise is number
crunching ed I presume from this what
have you come up with well I mean it's
it's because know where to begin in some
in some senses this is not about policy
and your two guests we're talking about
that a moment ago you know they're
particularly in the Tory manifest day
we're not saying massive promises we're
seeing a lot of promises and the labor
manifesto and they've got a lot further
than they have last time around but it's
really when you actually kind of look at
the numbers and try to get a sense of
you know how much difference is there
between the parties you come to some
rather interesting conclusions and I've
got a few can I show some charts going
but I've got some choice then we can
have a look at they'll just give you a
sense of kind of you know what is going
on in this election who is promising
more who's promising to spend more and
this one is is is one actually I've said
on TV just a few days ago basically this
shows you how much each different party
is proposing to increase spending by by
the final year of the Parliament okay
and there's a pretty clear pattern there
isn't there I mean not only not only do
you have Labor doing an enormous amount
in that that 80 billion or 80 is just
over 80 billion that's about double what
they were promising last time around so
labour have gone much further than they
have last time around the Lib Dems do so
they've gone a lot much a lot further
than they have last time but the Tories
look at that Tory bar and that is about
as low as you can possibly imagine it
they are not promising to increase
current spending much and what we're
talking about here what these bars show
you basically is how much they're
planning to increase spending on you
know nurses salaries on education it's
current spending so this is not spending
on roads or rail some of the stuff
they're talking about this is spending
on the state on its day to day functions
and what you can see there is labour
really want to change matters enormous
ly it's worth mentioning on top of that
they will also want to raise taxes
enormously so they're planning to raise
taxes to pay for all of that and on that
sense I know this was this was raised in
one of the forensic interviews the other
night but but aren't labour trying to
raise these taxes from actually a pretty
narrow tax pose yeah that's I mean the
plan is and they're they make no bones
about this is they want to raise it from
the top 5% of the income tax paying
population and there's let's say some
raised eyebrows to put it mildly within
the world of economists about whether
you can actually do that because I mean
because it's risky to an extent it is it
is risky because a lot of these people
are more mobile so they can move abroad
if if need be it's risky because you
know it might stifle ambition a lot of
people tend to think actually you know
you want to have tax rates at the tops
that aren't so high that people just
don't bother actually working the extra
hour and when you give fascinatingly
when you looked at the labor manifesto
that in theory they you know if you just
take a slide rule and say okay
everything everything else equal if
everyone stayed and did their jobs this
is how much you'd raise from this tax
and it was about it was over ten billion
I think it's about eleven twelve billion
pounds when they kind of calculated how
many people would either leave the
country work less just basically earn
less as a response to that tax they haft
the potential income from it so you know
they are expecting that people are going
to respond to this and they're gonna
respond by not necessarily working at
all but that is their pitch their
pictures to spend a lot more as you can
see there and to raise taxes a lot more
as well and if we go on to the next
chart so that this shows you current
spending start spending on you know
day-to-day running of the government
let's look at the next one that shows
you capital spending and here there is a
you know there's less of a difference
here this is the spending on you know
whether it's hs2 whether it's big
projects to try and sort out roads or
broadband that's where those bars come
in the higher they are the more you're
planning to spend on it again labor
miles ahead of everyone else but not
quite to the same degree as before and
the interesting thing is the tories
planning to spend an awful lot hmmm what
that basically means is all those
promises to eliminate the deficit to try
and you know get to zero
they have gone they've gone completely
and you know it's the first election
actually that the Tories have been
promising to do that and you know we
focus a lot on labor and they have
obviously got a very radical set of
policies they say themselves you know
this is this is a radical manifesto by
most measures it's pretty much the most
radical that we've seen since 1983 since
Michael fertile beyond but
the Tories when you look at what they're
doing whether it's the minimum wage
they're trying to raise the minimum wage
they have caps on energy prices they
want to end austerity you know you can
debate about how much they're doing it
actually the Tory manifesto this time
around is not different from the Ed
Miliband labor manifesto in economic
terms this may sound crazy but it's not
that in for the Ed Miliband labor
manifesto in 2015 so the Tories have
shifted to the left in economic terms I
mean there's lots of other you know you
talk about broke so you can talk about
what they're doing on justice or Home
Affairs but in economic terms they have
shifted to the left and part of that is
illustrated that they want to spend a
lot more money how much of any of these
levels of spending can it be argued will
stimulate the economy well in theory in
theory spending a lot more on you know
infrastructure should be productivity
enhancing you know people if you're if
you're making the roads better than
people are able to get to work better
you're able to put more trucks on them
if you're making rail better people can
dito get to work and then you can have
more trade in practice though we just we
just don't know and a lot of this will
be paid for out of borrowing but let's
let's just go on to the next couple of
slides because we can see kind of you
know a bit of historical content so you
don't mind me show I don't Saturday
morning but you know I've got lots of
charts and I use like ever it's like an
overhead projector so it's I love it
that's what home is like you know
Saturday mornings so so this shows you
tax revenues as a percent of GDP and and
just look at you know look at where we
are now in comparison to the past I'm
allowed to go to the wall and connect
you know right now you know the tour
right now we're kind of hat there that
is of still about the highest that we've
been you know since they kind of you
know the really actually the 1960s so
you're talking about kind of you know
really high levels of taxing can put in
a historical comparison the toys are
going to raise them a little bit higher
lib dems a bit higher than that and look
at labour I mean that's raising to the
highest level basically since the 1950s
so you're talking here about a very high
level of Taxation in comparison to the
historical average and then have a look
at the next chart and we can see
spending and here government spending
it's nowhere near as high as we saw in
the period of financial crisis of course
because you know that was like no you
know banks being bailed out and stuff
but you're getting up with the tour
with the Tories you're kind of staying
about where you are which is still
higher than any Tory government since
Macmillan but labor look at that they
want to change the nature of the state
you know you're talking about getting
public spending up to levels that we
have rarely if ever seen in this country
outside of a financial crisis and you
know that was another economic crisis
that was when the IMF intervenes in the
1970s so these these are big shifts in
the nature of the state and I'm gonna
come back to this because we've got the
next have a look at the next chart this
basically I think shows you the
comparison between you know where the UK
would be under these different types of
spending plans compared with other
countries around the world
and actually here it doesn't look that
radical does it so no you know the UK
there you can see is that that that dark
blue bowl that's where we are at the
moment the conservative plans would kind
of push up pushed us up a tiny bit the
Lib Dems do so but we're still more or
less you know with between Cyprus and
Israel below Canada below Iceland below
Spain and labor their plans although
they look radical in you know historical
terms that last chart look at where we
are there where between the Netherlands
and Portugal and below Germany you know
so what labor are proposing is to turn
the UK into you know a country that is a
bit more like the European model but
they're proposing to do it in a very
dramatic and quick fashion and like you
asked you know they're proposing to do
it all those other countries like
Germany Portugal they are there because
a lot of people within the center so not
your top 5% are paying more taxes and
labor are proposing to do it just
raising taxes from the top and I think
that's that's an objection I think many
economists have if you're going to get
there which is not an unreasonable
assumption then eh can you do it this
quickly and be can you do it just
raising your taxes on the top 5% the
answer I think for most of them is is no
or at least a big question mark ok there
we must leave it I have more choice but
I mean I know
[Laughter]